[Musique]
balance ton salaire c'est le nouveau
hashtag qui a vu le jour sur Twitter
alors que la pénurie de carburant
continue d'impacter le quotidien des
Français le groupe Total énergie a
publié un communiqué rappelant que les
opérateurs total gagnant au moyen un
salaire de 4300 euros par mois et qui a
augmenté de 3,5 % en janvier suite à ce
chiffre qui a suscité un vif débat les
internautes ont décidé de dévoiler leur
salaire sur Twitter je gagne 1500 après
25 ans à la poste je touche 986 euros
par mois en tant qu'employé de station
essence infirmier 11 ans d'ancienneté
horaires décalées travaillent un
week-end sur deux 2100 euros par mois et
vous les chroniqueurs seriez-vous prêt à
balancer votre salaire
[Musique]
alors seriez-vous prêt à balancer votre
salaire
non mais c'est quoi moi je ne le donne
je le donne j'enlève la négation si
Benjamin et Mathieu donnent le leur
parce que chaque année je donne le mien
et jamais donc j'ai une proposition
alors faire vous donnez votre salaire
non bien sûr
et plutôt fier de ce que je gagnais ça
m'a valu tellement d'ennuis tellement de
problèmes ça m'a valu une telle
réputation il est conséquences sont
tellement importantes
suffisamment dans la merde comme ça et
en facture et en plus je paye et en plus
par rapport à ces gens là
ce serait indécent de le faire et j'ai
pas envie de le faire et en revanche je
soutiens complètement le mouvement et
c'est vrai que comme l'a dit Raymond
hier c'est vrai que quand ils ont dit
ils ont mal payés à deux trois mille
euros brut par mois par rapport à
d'autres c'est effectivement compliqué
si je le trouve pas c'est parce que là
on s'en fout de ce que tu veux dire
de nous embrouiller on s'en fout de ce
que tu dis je vous embrouilles mais je
dirais pas je dirais plus jamais voilà
j'ai la grille des salaires je peux la
sortir
vous vous êtes le seul à dire oui moi
j'ai dit oui parce que j'ai déjà dit ici
j'ai déjà dit que je prenais 2000 dans
le camion et que je prenais 2000 voir
2005 plus ici mais maintenant que j'ai
plus de camion quasiment j'ai que ici le
salaire que j'ai touché le mois dernier
j'ai touché 3188 voilà mais ça c'est pas
du bruit
c'est beaucoup plus après il y a les
impôts carrés
je peux surtout reparler d'augmentation
que je devais avoir ce qu'on est pas il
dortation je devais avoir un
augmentation moi cette année avec les ce
que tu me dis là tu l'as eu cette année
en janvier prochain
moi je prends 500 balles par soir ici
[Musique]
et ce qui est beau avec ce reportage
c'est que là juste avant pendant le
magnéto Mathieu m'a confié qu'on ait
gagné par mois
il me l'a dit et en vrai attends on en
parle et en vrai
pas du tout mais c'est un beau chiffre
et euh
non non mais je vais vous dire vous
savez quoi voilà c'est très simple sur
l'argent c'est que moi je le dis pas
c'est un truc d'éducation catholique
parce qu'en fait à partir du moment où
on donne un montant si toi tu gagnes
plus que toi ou que tu gagnes plus que
toi on commence à regarder les gens avec
une sorte de hiérarchie ou avec Raymond
tu es plus brillant que j'entends qui
est plus brillant que machin et donner
l'argent c'est c'est une échelle
bizarrement moi je parle des gens
différemment je vais très honnête je
n'ai aucune idée de de vos revenus
mais c'est surtout par rapport à
l'extérieur
de la transparence ou quoi qu'on dise en
fait ce sera un dessin et donc on va
nous dire mais est-ce que tu es légitime
toi parler tous les soirs de telles
choses de tel mouvement social alors que
toi tu es effectivement tu es nanti tu
es extrêmement privilégié et évidemment
c'est le cas tu es donc hors sol et
c'est évidemment le cas et pour autant
j'ai connu la galère j'ai connu des
problèmes des gros problèmes de Free je
sais ce que c'est que de ne rien avoir
je sais que ce que c'est que de ne rien
avoir le 10 du mois j'ai été poursuivi
par les huissiers avec ma maman donc je
sais ce que c'est tout ce que je peux
dire c'est que quand j'ai été mannequin
puisque c'est des métiers précaires
quand tes mannequins on travaille pas
plus que à 25 ans après on est on sent
le sapin je crois que j'ai écrivain
et ben c'est pas le même travail puisque
moi pour un défilé je pouvais être payé
par exemple à l'époque je sais pas 10000
ou 15000 euros pour un des chiffres
et pour écrire un livre alors que ça me
prenait un an de mon temps c'était 2000
euros la valoir donc voilà donc à peu
près tous les tarifs on peut avoir aussi
tous les tarifs en tant que artiste ou
alors est-ce que vous considérez comme
riche aujourd'hui
et c'est vrai qu'il y a toujours cette
question qui se pose et je la pose au
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent c'est
vrai que maintenant tout le monde donne
son salaire sur les réseaux etc à partir
de quelle somme ou partir de quoi vous
considérez comme étant riche
Géraldine moi ma grand-mère par exemple
elle a un petit appartement qu'elle a
acheté grâce à ma maman et tout ça grâce
à ce qu'on lui a donné donc je considère
qu'elle est à l'abri ma mère elle est
pas encore propriétaire elle a bientôt
elle doit travailler jusqu'à 70 ans pour
être propriétaire là et quand moi
j'aurai un petit appartement à moi
propriétaire là je considérais que je
suis riche moi je suis locataire je peux
pas être propriétaire je suis trop
vieille pour emprunter donc je considère
que je ne suis pas riche mais je suis
très très j'aime bien j'aime bien savoir
vous et je suis sûr que c'est
intéressant pour les téléspectateurs
vous à partir de quand vous vous
considérez comme alors déjà moi je me
considère comme riche je voilà je le dis
à partir de quelle somme vous considérez
comment 4000 euros net par mois pour moi
c'est des ça passe le seuil des gens
riches donc vous êtes comme je gagne
plus d'accord tu dis comment je dis que
je suis riche et tout ça il a pas
d'enfants
et puis là c'est bientôt plus de mal et
aussi
quand même c'est plutôt pas mal de
l'endroit où tu vis c'est il y a les
loyers ici sont exorbitants
je parle en général Mathieu moi j'ai
parlé plus en capital parce que les
salaires c'est quoi pour toi quelqu'un
de riche quelqu'un qui c'est quelqu'un
qui possède en actif net c'est-à-dire on
enlève les les emprunts un actif net
c'est quelqu'un qui possède 5 millions
d'euros ah ouais ouais
pour moi voilà c'est quelqu'un qui est
réussi 5 millions d'euros c'est
quelqu'un qui est riche quelqu'un qui
est à l'abri c'est-à-dire quelqu'un
il est à la maison
mais attention je ne les ai pas je suis
pas riche oui mais moi je n'aurais
jamais j'aurais jamais la phrase de
Gilles que là encore je pourrais gifler
mais je le ferai pas cette année qui
vous dit qu'à partir de 4000 euros
encore une fois ça me va pas parce que
le principe si tu veux tu sais un jour
il veut la preuve d'économique très
intelligent un économiste qui avait en
92 on a supprimé la première classe dans
le dans le métro et la journée ce qui
lui dit on a supprimé la première classe
dans le métro c'est une grande avancée
et il avait répondu non la grande
avancée ça aurait été de supprimer la
seconde et ben je pense qu'effectivement
le principe de ce pays c'est de les gens
qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent à gagner
plus et les amis vers le haut et c'est
pas toi avoir des espèces de fausses à
la maison
c'est pas riche tu vis à Paris tu es pas
quelqu'un de riche là c'est parce qu'il
y a une caméra
tu es Guignols
dans le cul c'est Daniel à côté
on n'est pas riche on n'est pas riche
mais on vit très parlé en général 4000
euros c'est c'est un salaire énorme
c'est le salaire rêvé de millions de
dizaines d'années
tais-toi
tu peux avoir la voiture que tu aimes tu
peux partir en weekend
par mois pour moi c'est être riche
c'est quoi être riche
si tu es propriétaire et que tu as 4 ou
5000 euros par mois à la fin du mois tu
peux faire quelque chose bah bien sûr il
faut les tenir sur les animaux
honnêtement 200 milliards
être riche
franchement oui bah oui il a vérité
autour de 50000 € par mois
50000 € par mois
c'est très très riche
100000 euros à partir de combien casse
tu as dit on est riche
moi je pense qu'au-delà de 100.000 euros
on est très riche
il pense vraiment que lui oui Benjamin
il dit la vérité
avant tu vois ce que je veux dire
par mois je ne savais plus où mettre
pendant pas peu de temps je savais plus
mettre plus de sens vraiment tu aurais
dû nous appeler
maintenant c'est mieux
les spectateurs on est vous êtes sans
limite vous avez pas envie d'acheter une
bagnole je vais acheter une voiture
partir en voyage vous avez gagné plus de
100000 € par mois pendant oui pendant 2
ans j'étais à plus de 300 € par mois
vous savez pourquoi je dis bah moi je
vais vous dire moi pour moi c'est c'est
pas riche ça puisque regardez en vrai
derrière aujourd'hui vous pouvez plus le
faire donc en vrai être riche c'est
pouvoir aussi peut-être faire voilà
être à l'abri pendant des années
en fait par rapport à ça regardez
Benjamin à 100000 € par mois aujourd'hui
il s'est fait il s'est fait plaisir de
compter à combien tu considères moi je
pense que vraiment
les gens qui disent qu'ils n'ont pas de
problème d'argent et qui sont riches
c'est 20000 euros par mois
ah non je pense pas 100000 € net
on est très riche
quand même un gap
quand on est moi j'ai 50 ans et je me
dis mais quand je serai à la retraite et
c'est ça en fait on vit avec quoi parce
que les retraites aujourd'hui elles sont
toutes petites en fait pour moi être
riche c'est quand on est vieux et ben on
vit dans des conditions décentes avec un
bel appart on fait ce qu'on veut on
profite de la vie on n'est pas malade
enfin vous voyez enfin je veux dire
c'est que on a une qualité de vie
extraordinaire et en fait globalement il
faut avoir beaucoup d'argent pour être
je suis d'accord c'est 10 15000 quoi
tiens ce weekend Fatou allez on part on
part ce weekend pas très loin
de billets d'avion de nuit dans un bel
hôtel et les restos et tout bah pardon
c'est à 4000 balles tu as fait un gate
au moins total je te le dis hein tu vas
voir
dans l'acceptation des gens l'idée quand
on dit oh je lui il est riche c'est
qu'il ne pense pas aux gens
c'est des stars de joueurs de foot vous
êtes malade c'est vraiment il y a des
réponses très diverses puisque Gilles
vous dites à 4000 € net par mois on est
riche c'est ce que dit aussi Jean-Luc
franchement c'est ça bah bien sûr
d'autant qu'aujourd'hui les impôts sont
prélevés à la source donc 4000 euros net
par mois ça veut dire un salaire sans
doute de 7000 euros bruts c'est énorme
ce sont des salaires énormes
on disait on dit que par exemple
effectivement c'est un très beau salaire
c'est un salaire de quelqu'un aisé mais
moi dans mon dans mon imaginaire riche
c'est quelqu'un qui ne pense pas à
l'argent qui n'a pas de souci mais
personnellement
[Applaudissements]
Guillaume mais Gilles est insupportable
de démagogie à 4000 euros par mois on
est pas riche être riche cette fortune
c'est dépenser sans compter c'est
posséder plusieurs biens c'est aller au
restaurant quand on veut voyager quand
on veut à 45000 il y a même des
personnes à Paris qui gagnent 10000
euros par mois ce qui est un énorme
salaire et qui ne sont pas riches qui ne
voyage pas quand elles veulent qui ne
peuvent pas les horaires
vous dites ça pour culpabiliser les gens
pour que les gens s'estiment heureux de
gagner 2000 3000 4000 euros c'est ce
sont des très bons salaires ce sont des
salaires qui malheureusement sont rares
en France mais on est pas riches à 4000
euros par mois je suis désolé
vous vous mélangez les les Français qui
ont un certain train de vie et vous
mélangez par exemple les joueurs de foot
les gens de la télé en fait c'est juste
pas les mêmes proportions de salaire en
fait donc tu peux pas dire que un
français peut s'estimer riche lorsqu'ils
gagnent 50000 ou 100000 euros par mois
parce que à côté de là il est dans un
autre monde en fait
l'avocats qui peuvent gagner ça il y a
des gens dans la finance qui a fait des
footballeurs
footballeur à 50000 par mois limite il
est pas hyper bien payé
50 milles je sais pas combien de valeur
à 1000000 en même temps 20000 hein
et les gens qui regardent ce soir à la
télé je trouve sans doute insupportable
parce que vous êtes vraiment hors-sol et
vous êtes dans votre microcosme de Jean
du foot
et en plus
vous êtes pénible de ramener tout à
Paris je signale pari dans la vie à
Paris parce que
on parle pas de Paris ils arrêtent pas
de dire Paris pas du tout mais non ils
ont pas vu Paris un moment ils ont donné
l'exemple de Paris
à 4000 € Daniel a combien pour combien
alors moi j'ai je vais vous dire voilà
je vais vous dire j'ai toujours été payé
à peu près 4000 € brut et je me suis
longtemps estimé riche à part j'avais
deux heures et 2h30 de transport en
commun par jour et ça pour moi c'est
vraiment la pauvreté c'est l'horreur
mais sinon je trouve que c'est un peu de
la team de Gilles c'est un peu de la
team de Gilles
je me trouvais déjà riche sauf que
maintenant je donne 5000 euros par mois
pour l'aide à domicile pour ma mère donc
maintenant dans la misère je suis très
je suis vraiment rien alors là j'ai la
chance en ce moment de travailler un
petit peu pour d'autres choses sinon je
commençais à prendre dans mes économies
donc la richesse voilà elle est elle est
quand même 1000
€. donc dans le cas Daniel qui gagne ça
mais elle n'est pas riche en fait
par mois
riche et tu pars en weekend quand tu
veux tu as une ou deux voitures tu vas
dans le reste tu veux et quand tu fais
quelque chose c'est pas un arbitrage ça
ne change pas sur autre chose
je suis désolé j'ai peut-être pas des
besoins des mois maintenant
mais après il y a les il y a il y a les
gens riches et je vous regarde à dessin
il y a les gens riches voilà il y a des
gens qui n'ont pas besoin de réfléchir
quand on ne réfléchit pas l'argent c'est
qu'on écrit ou un truc on va revoir pas
du tout la richesse on voit pas c'est
pas
le vélo
presque normal mais c'est riche ici
je parle pas d'un exemple de me faire
excuse-moi d'avoir réveillé
moi je pense que comme Gilles à partir
de 4 4 5000 euros tu commences à être
très très aisé parce que tu as déjà deux
fois le salaire médian des Français
c'est 1008 le salaire médian en France
et la plupart à 1400 donc quand tu es
dans des sommes à 4000 si tu as une vie
si tu as pas une maman à faire garder si
tu as pas il y a 4 enfants si tu as pas
des actifs tout seul tu commences à être
très très aisé et moi mon repère c'est
toujours 9000 euros pour moi 9000 euros
tu es riche fin du débat parce que ça
représente 0,8% de la population c'est à
dire que si on te donne 9000 euros net
par mois
pour 100 et ben pour moi
je dis que je dis là à pas tort à 4500
euros 4000 euros tu es riche
il faut parler par rapport à ce qu'on
sait je vais pas dire je vais pas dire
mais pourquoi
c'est fait c'est 0,8
je prends un steak et je suis content de
prendre ce steak parce que j'ai de la
chance par rapport à la table à côté je
suis pas sûr qu'il peut prendre la même
technique
je me pose pas de question si je touche
4005 il est bien ton exemplaire par
contre comparer aux autres
moi j'ai un pote très riche qui m'a dit
un jour tu sais je vais te dire ça sert
à rien d'être très riche je mangerai pas
de steak non mais c'est vrai tu vois
bien sûr c'est vrai ouais
ça c'est des belles phrases moi il y a
toujours une phrase tu vas mourir avec
ton argent tu sais l'argent il va aller
d'une maison
en voiture alors qu'il y a demain
ah oui mais je suis en vélo connard mais
je vais me déplacer
12 maisons vous avez 14 villas
ils sont lourds
sont lourds excusez-moi
il est venu en vélo
ah la barre merci en tout cas c'est vrai
en tout cas vous vous connaissez pas
donner votre salaire voilà
même grande gueule
si vous faites ce que vous voulez je
vous le dis voilà il y en a qui vont lui
donner on est hyper confortable ce
serait pas exactement ce que donne
toujours
salaire
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire aux gens
tes enquêtes tes machins j'ai jamais dit
je le donner
tu passes ton temps en français quand on
te demande ton salaire tu t'es tu t'es
foncé comme un soufflet voilà ce qu'on
va faire tu sais ce qu'on va faire pour
montrer à quel point tu es faux je vais
donner mon salaire et donc tu vas donner
ton salaire d'accord non mais il est con
ou quoi pourquoi tu donnes pas ton
salaire
tu veux que je le donne ton salaire mais
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi elle est partie des salaires on
a eu dans le cul de Gilles
cette ambiance avec les stars insulter
par un gars qui fait 15 dogs de merde
sur Disney et il ouvre toujours
[Applaudissements]
il est le meilleur chroniqueur le
meilleur quoi
il est indispensable c'est le seul qui a
fait toutes les émissions depuis le
début de l'année les gars donc
posez-vous les bonnes questions après la
vraie richesse et comme le patron total
c'est pas forcément les salaires c'est
les dividendes non la vraie richesse
c'est surtout je vous dis je veux dire
une bonne amitié mais c'est la santé
[Applaudissements]
de la planète qui est parti très vite et
je me disais dans ma tête à chaque fois
je me disais tu vois ce gars là il
aurait dit il lui avait dit bah tu sais
quoi tu as plus rien tu as plus d'argent
tu as plus rien mais tu es guéri mais tu
repars à zéro t'as rien du tout je te
donne zéro euro mais il aurait signé
tout de suite et c'est vrai et c'est
vrai que ça en vrai c'est une leçon non
mais sans déconner je pense souvent à
Steve Jobs et Bill Gates qui est un des
hommes les plus riches de du monde à
tout donner à des applications
je rappelle que je suis son fils
je m'appelle Cyril Gates voilà